is way pretty gonna have to choke a
bitch I'm Rick James bitch yourself
ooh
oh as my baby son welcome to the
first and maybe only racial grams here
in New York City and the blacks have
actually won the first pick so long
fried rice hello fries
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
shut the up
stop yelling at me please y'all can't
stop yelling that's how I talk this is
some African statues I don't really
with Africa good stop and if that's not
Balder than me y'all excuse me I'm going
scuba diving with crystalline Aquaman
giddyup
I have what's known as a venereal
disease how did you get it from
because I what time did you tell him to
be here I have a cloth but he's always
late he'll be here in three two space
niggas the United States from space does
anyone up for a game of basketball they
come out they still got all the same
they be wearing it before there's
only two of these left in the world this
look came on his face
[Applause]
[Music]
yah-yah-yah Lil John Daniel a fractured
your arm
purify yourself in the waters of the
lake minnetonka PA louses I hope you all
die a fiery death when the media hits
next Tuesday come on babe with us get at
it
[Music]
you